we could have a debate about what the
most interesting cell in the human body
is but i think easily the neuron would
make the top five and if not just
because the cell itself is interesting
the fact that it essentially makes up
our brain and our nervous system and is
responsible for the thoughts and our
feelings and and and maybe for all of
our sentience i think uh what would
easily make it the top one or two cells
so what i want to do is first just show
you what a neuron looks like and of
course this is kind of the perfect
example this isn't what all neurons look
like and then we're going to talk a
little bit about how it performs at its
function which is essentially
communication essentially
transmitting signals across its lengths
depending on the signals it receives so
if i were to draw a neuron let me pick a
better color
so let me draw
my brush size a little bit thinner so
let's say i have a neuron it looks
something like this so in the middle you
have your
soma and then from the soma so let me
draw the nucleus
draw my try my best so this is a nucleus
just like any cell's nucleus and then
the soma is considered the body of the
neuron and then the neuron has these
little things sticking out from it
that keep branching off that keep
branching off maybe they look something
like this
i don't want to spend too much time just
drawing the neuron but you've probably
seen drawings like this before
and these branches off of the soma of
the neuron off of its body these are
called adendite dendrites
dendrites and they can keep splitting
off like that
i want to do a fairly reasonable drawing
so i'll spend a little time
doing that the one last dendrite just
like that so these right here these are
dendrites
and these tend to be and nothing is
always the case in biology sometimes
different parts of different cells
perform other functions but these tend
to be where the neuron receives its
signal
and we'll talk more about what it means
to
receive and transmit a signal in this
video and probably in the next view so
this is where it receives the signal
and then so this is the dendrite this
right here is the soma
soma means body this is the body of the
neuron and then we have
and then we have kind of a you can
almost view it as a tail of of the
neuron it's called the axon
the axon
it a neuron could be you know a
reasonably normal size cell although
there is a huge range but the axons can
be quite long they could be short
sometimes in the brain you might have
very small axons but you might have
axons that go down the spinal column or
that go along one of your limbs or you
know if you're talking about a dinosaur
along with a dinosaur's limb so the axon
can actually stretch several feet not
all neurons axons are several feet but
they could be and this is really where a
lot of the
the distance of the signal gets traveled
so let me draw the axon
so the axon will look something like
this
and at the end
it ends at the axon terminal
where it can connect to other
dendrites or maybe to other types of
tissue or muscle if the point of this
neuron is to tell a muscle to do
something so at the end of the axon you
have the axon terminal right there
do my best to draw it
like that let me label it so this is the
axon
this is the axon terminal
terminal
and you'll sometimes hear the word the
point at which the soma or the body of
the neuron connects to the axon is often
referred to as the axon hillock maybe
you can kind of use kind of a lump it
starts to form the axon so it's the axon
hillock
and then we're going to talk about
actually i think there's a c there
we're going to talk about how how the
impulses travel and a huge part in what
allows them to travel efficiently
efficiently are these insulating cells
around the axon
these insulating cells around the axon
we're going to talk about this in detail
and how they actually work but it's good
just to have the anatomical structure
first so these are called schwann cells
cells and they're covering they make up
the myelin sheath so this covering this
insulation at different intervals around
the axon this is called the myelin
sheath
so schwann cells make up the myelin
sheath i'll do one more just like that
so i'll say schwann cells or
myelin
myelin sheath
and then these little spaces between the
myelin sheath just so we have all the
terminology from uh so we know the
entire anatomy of the neuron these are
called the nodes of ranvier
nodes
of ranvier
i guess they're named after ranveer
maybe he was the guy who looked and saw
they have these little these little
slots here where you don't have myelin
sheets so these are the nodes of ranvier
so the general idea as i mentioned is
that you get a signal here and we're
going to talk more about what the signal
means and then that signal gets trans
actually the signals can be sum so you
might have one little signal right there
another signal right there and then
you'll have a maybe a larger signal
there and there and that the combined
effects of these signals get summed up
and they travel to the hillock and if
they're large enough if they're large
enough they're going to trigger an
action potential
on the axon which will cause a signal to
travel down the balance of the axon and
then over here it might be connected via
synapses synapses to other dendrites or
muscles and we'll talk more about
synapses and those might help trigger
other things and so you're saying what's
triggering these things here well this
could be the terminal end
of other neurons axes sorry axons like
in the brain they could be this could be
some type of sensory neuron this could
be on a taste bud someplace so when you
know a salt molecule somehow can trigger
it or sugar molecule or this might be
some type of stretch sensor it could be
a whole bunch of different things and
we'll talk more about the different
types of neurons